Another demonstration and another arrest for
Alexei Navalny.
The years go by, but the pattern is always
the same.
For Navalny most protests end in jail with
weeks of administrative detention.
All in all he`s spent almost 5 months in jail
over the past two years.
The charge - organising illegal protests.
The only kind of protest possible in Russia,
say his supporters.
And this is the work that has made Navalny
a household name in Russia – exposing what
he says are the corrupt personal fortunes
of Russia‘s leaders.
In spite of a near total reporting ban on
his activities in the mainstream media.
This mansion, Navalny alleges, is just one
of Vladimir Putin’s private retreats.
WAY BEYOND the means of the president’s
officially declared earnings.
Prime Dmitry Medvedev and what Navalny says
are his private palaces and Italian vineyard
is the subject of a video that has been watched
by more than 27 million people.
At a time when ordinary Russians are being
asked to tighten their belts.
In public at least Russia‘s leaders have
long refused to discuss the substance of Navalny’s
allegations or even refer to him by name.
But that seems to be changing.
In September the head of Russias National
Guard published a video message to Navalny
online, challenging him to a duel and promising
to make “mincemeat” of him.
This came after an investigation by Navalny’s
team alleging widespread corruption in the
way the National Guard buys food for its troops.
The only problem – Navalny was once again
in jail at the time and unable to respond.
When he is out of jail Navalny is able to
mobilise his supporters like no other leader
of the Russian opposition.
Not just in Moscow but around the country.
As public unrest grows over unpopular plans
to raise the pension age, that is a threat
the Kremlin seems to be taking very seriously
indeed.
But equally the authorities seem unwilling
to lock Alexey Navalny up for any length of
time, at the risk of turning him INTO A MARTYR/PRISONER
OF CONSCIENCE.
Instead, for now it seems like his frequent
trips to prison are set to continue – as
here in September, where police were waiting
to detain him as soon as he left prison on
another charge.